nous allons terminer ce journal avec
l'héroïne des nuits fauves et de
l'accompagnatrice romane bohringer bien
sûr et en avignon où elle présente une
lecture de l'écumé des jours de boris
vian en exclusivité pour france 2 les
deux michels trudeau vicié levasseur ont
pu suivre romane et ils sont tombés tous
deux sous le charme de sa grâce et de sa
spontanéité
l'émotion de romain vous ragez sur les
lieux mêmes de ses débuts voilà on la
comprend
inconnu il ya deux ans c'est ici qu'elle
se révèle dans la tempête de shakespeare
avec peter brook m c'était un endroit
magique oies et festival d'avignon
sam pour moi c'était comme c'était
vierge par rapport à tout ce à quoi je
connaissais rien et deux ans c'est court
et deux ans de ma vie à la changer
complètement part à changer mais s'est
passé tellement de choses quand je
reviens et 6r coeur qui bat quoi gîte
toutes les images qui reviennent ya deux
ans j'avais pascal est à ce retour
l'accomplît par amour de boris vian dans
le cadre de lecture organisé par là et
ça c'est des la société des auteurs
comme il a fait un beau cadeau quand
même mon père m'a transmis un avis
non
séance de travail autour de l'écumé des
jours le livre qui ne la quitte par
plusieurs églises
romane bohringer fasse un nouveau défi
faire vivre les mots de son auteur
préféré travail dit elle à voix basse et
pour cela qu'il n'est plus dont la garde
est celui-là on a gardé la jouerie
t'allonger sur 51 au mahdi j'essayais de
le proposer des choses mais elle savait
très bien ce qu'elle voulait me dit
boris vian pourquoi que je vis pourquoi
que je vis pour la jambe jaune d'une
femme blonde appuyer ou sous le plein
soleil pour la voile rond d'un pointu du
port pour l'ombre des stores ce café
glacé convoi dans un tube pour toucher
le sable voir le fond de l'eau qui
devient si bleu qui descend si bas avec
les poissons les calmes poissons ils
paissent le font volte dessus des algues
cheveux comme un oiseau lents comme
l'oiseau bleu pourquoi que je vis parce
que c'est humain
la cour d'honneur du palais des papes là
où un temps de grands depuis villaron
jouer c'est comme un appel pour cette
toute jeune et déjà grandes actrices
tels lieux qui vous fait rêver on en
rêverait pour moi on a envie de jouer
dans un lieu comme ça moi c'est une
façon de jouer et j'aurais fait de la
plongée envie voir les gens s'amusent
bassement j'ai 12 ans à nous deux à
vigneault